Drake breaks his silence in his ongoing
feud with Pusha T confused always
thought you weren't black enough afraid
to grow it cuz your fro wouldn't happen
no Pusha T dropped what sounds like a
Drake dish track on Tuesday and this is
the cover art yes that's a young Drake
in blackface less than 24 hours later
the 31 year old Toronto native addressed
the photo on Instagram explaining the
backstory of the unedited image saying
it was used out of context quote this
picture is from 2007 a time in my life
where I was an actor and I was working
on a project that was about young black
actors struggling to get roles being
stereotyped and typecast he added quote
the photos represented how
african-americans were once wrongfully
portrayed and entertainment while Drake
made no direct mention of Pusha T's name
or his song in his post it's easy to
connect the dots
Pusha T calls out Drake's parents Dennis
and Sandy Graham on the track and
alludes to Drizzy having a secret son a
recent tabloid story a baby's involved
is deeper than breath we talking
character let me keep with the facts
you are hiding a child let that boy come
home this all comes after Drake
seemingly sparked the rap war dropping
doopy freestyle which seemingly takes
aim at Pusha T's drug dealer past maybe
you might have sold a college kids for
naked Mercedes but you act like you sold
drugs for Escobar in the eighties
you